are you ready I'm so ready it's already
this movie is incredible it is funny it
is adventurous I love everything about
it and I know that you're one of the
writers for the film as well so does
your son like it now it's enjoying it
yeah yeah he was a fan from the
beginning okay he likes to push my
buttons but he's kind of gotten really
into the Marvel Universe because of it
he's I'm not his favorite it's you still
no no no he thinks like the winter he's
big into the Winter Soldier oh really
that guy's that guy's amazing he thinks
he's super cool
and but he loves all the films and he
does think this one's pretty cool and
he's very excited to see this one which
he will be seeing in a few days the
dynamic between the daughter and father
really touched me it's so beautiful in
this film and it's so important to this
film as well
is it art imitating life is this what
you do with your daughter build a Ford
and have that kind of adventure and all
of that with my own daughter and and
yeah and it's it's uh there are many
things she gets my daughters eight and
so she she really connects to this and
it's it's awesome and it's it is a big
part of the film and not just my
relationship with Cassie you know hopes
relationship with Hank and it's is this
movie is really there's a lot about
parents and kids so yeah and the balance
of being a father and ant-man right it's
hard that's hard in real life too yeah
it's big thing now in terms of having
your own superhero moment in your life
has you have you ever had a moment where
you stepped in and solved a situation I
would like to think so okay yeah think
of anything where I stepped in and
solved a situation with the kids or
anything I mean that kind of starts to
happen on a on a on a regular basis
where you're just trying to separate you
know like an argument might be happening
or let the pretzel split the pretzel
right there's one left break it in half
that's true that's true
no this is basically what being a parent
is yeah I know it is isn't it telling
your kids to split the big we are the
present I'll go dark I will go vain but
you know I'm Canadian and we love nice
people I think it's very sexy I mean
Ryan Reynolds he's nice he's hot right
you say you're not a nice guy which is
hard to believe but you weren't no I
didn't I I don't I don't say that there
was an article reason yeah yeah that's a
yeah I'll I said well I go it where all
people are very yeah multi-dimensional
and complex and there are moments when
we're nice we're moments when we're not
yeah nice because of whatever's going on
with us and and I'm not one thing all
the time like nobody is one thing yeah
time except Ryan Reynolds who is just
nice and sexy all the time what's your
favorite not so nice word
some might say it's too but face is
great I've never used that word yeah
it's just it's great Samuel Jackson
taught me mother yeah well that's a
classic